bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette édition
du 23 octobre du 7 8 sur tv fil 78 en
direct si vous nous rejoignez à 18
heures aujourd'hui nous reviendrons sur
les événements du 17 octobre 1961 sur
les déclarations de françois hollande le
chef de l'état a fait un premier pas
vers la reconnaissance des massacres et
qui se sont déroulées à paris alors des
manifestations pour l'indépendance de
l'algérie organisé par le fnl en plateau
henri pouillot vous militez pour cette
reconnaissance vous nous direz si vous
êtes satisfait de ces avancées invité
également au cours de la prochaine heure
bernadette pilloy la secrétaire de
l'association nationale des maîtres
chiens guides d'aveuglés elle lance une
pétition pour leur coeur leur compagnon
soit accepté par tous leurs compagnons
en formation vous verrez qu'ils ne sont
pas encore acceptée par tous et c'est
pour ça qu'elle a décidé de se mobiliser
et puis comme chaque mardi la page
environnement c'est avec valérie
auribeau bonsoir valérie decamp soir
wilfried ce soir nous allons aborder
l'éducation des enfants au développement
durable et pour ce faire nous aurons
caroline cellier de l'association y qui
nous présentera la mallette pédagogique
destiné aux professeurs qui enseignent
le développement durable aux 8 12 ans
merci la page environnement ce sera au
début de la seconde partie de cette
émission d'environ une demi-heure le
reste du sommaire en images à présent
les principaux titres de ce 23 octobre
les conseillers régionaux sont invités à
se pencher dès ce mercredi sur l'étude
du sdrif le schéma directeur de la
région ile de france
un document essentiel pour définir les
orientations en matière par exemple de
logement ou de transports dans la région
d'ici 2030 olivier paréja d'europe
écologie et les verts commentera ce
nouveau schéma régional le siac gère le
réseau d'assainissement de la courance
et englobe notamment des communes comme
aux repas et coignières des travaux de
rénovation sont en cours pour remplacer
les anciennes canalisations qui date est
d'une cinquantaine d'années une
cérémonie a lieu tous les jours à 18h30
devant l'arc de triomphe à paris en
toute discrétion l'allumage de la flamme
du soldat inconnu
et des jeunes de montigny le bretonneux
et de voisins-le-bretonneux viennent d'y
participer
le club de gymnastique rythmique de
maurepas et l'encours a tenu à bien
figurer à l'occasion des derniers
championnats départementaux c'était le
premier rendez-vous de la saison 1 manon
marque mara ans s'est imposé dans le
critérium seniors les images de cette
compétition à découvrir ce soir et on
commence donc avec les dernières
avancées autour de la reconnaissance par
l'état des événements du 17 octobre 1961
et je reçois donc henri pouillot bonsoir
je sept membres du collectif 17 octobre
1961 c'est ce jour que l'état français a
violemment réprimé une manifestation
interdite organisée par le fln pour
demander l'indépendance de l'algérie un
chiffre pour résumer la situation 51
il aura fallu cinquante et un nom avant
qu'un gouvernement ne reconnaissent ces
événements françois hollande la semaine
dernière par un communiqué ci a précisé
que le 17 octobre des algériens qui
manifestaient pour le droit à
l'indépendance ont été tués lors d'une
sanglante répression je cite toujours ce
communiqué la république reconnaît avec
lucidité
c'est fait cinquante et un ans après
cette tragédie vous êtes satisfait de
cette avancée du gouvernement oui c'est
un aspect très positif qui est enfin et
qui enfin arrive ça fait des années et
des années qu'on essaie de faire avancer
reconnaître 7,7 se fait par contre il ya
même dans ce communiqué il ya des choses
qui sont quand même un peu légères un
peu suffit un cas probable ce n'est pas
suffisant c'est un premier pas vraiment
l'ariège attachant que c'était un
communiqué ce n'est pas non plus une
déclaration officielle c'est resté par
écrit plus en plus la façon dont ce
communiqué a été fait est un peu que je
vais dire cavaliers parce que notre
collectif qui regroupe 70 associations
qui ont appelé à cette manifestation
d'octobre avait demandé un rendez vous
au président de la république le 15 au
20 septembre
n'ayant pas de réponse le 10 le 10
octobre
nous sommes allés déposer une lettre à
l'elysée dix ans que le père produits
suivants le 17 octobre à 15 heures ne
viendront chercher la rue la réponse le
sommet anniversaire de cet événement de
l'événement et trois heures avant la
manifestation qui devait avoir lieu le
rassemblement sur le pont saint-michel
et le président de la république nous a
laissé une heure sur le trottoir sans
accepté de nous recevoir nous n'avons
personne ne les lit jeunes n'a pas
trouvé de personnes pour nous recevoir
on nous a simplement proposé d'aller
avoir la réponse au ministère de
l'intérieur qui à côté
et en plus le communiqué a été fait
simplement par une agence par une une
déclaration à l'agencé afp
mais on n'a même pas été destinataire de
ce que ce communiqué vous intervenu le
17 octobre donc 2012 sans conscience ans
après les faits vous n'avez pas été
reçus et le communiqué a été publié via
la fp effectivement quelques quelques
heures après vous avez le sentiment que
la pression vous avez exercé qui a
permis d'obtenir ce communiqué nous
sommes arrivés que s'il n'y avait pas
une telle pression il y aurait pas eu de
communiqué du tout je sais un peu
l'impression qu'on a ressenti surtout
qu'il ya d'autres éléments qui viennent
un peu nous nous inquiéter par rapport
ce pack important quand même vous avez
tout de même le sentiment d'être un
tournant en tout cas de l'histoire ça
peut être un tournant si c'est pas le
premier pas et le dernier pas c'est ça
le problème important pourquoi je dis ça
c'est que hier en particulier laurent
fabius vient de déclarer et je veux pas
transformer sa ses propos qu'il n'était
pas question d'un traité d'amitié franco
algérien a préparé mais d'un partenariat
stratégique centrée sur les domaines
économiques éducatifs énergie qui
énergétique pardon et pourquoi pas
militaire les problèmes de droits de
l'homme et la reconnaissance des crimes
d'état des crimes contre l'humanité
commis pendant la
la guerre d'algérie pendant le
colonialisme on n'est pas sous silence
complètement
et pourtant c'est une demande forte y
compris du peuple algérien mais aussi
toutes les victimes de cette période de
que enfin reconnaissent que la le se
passe c'est important parce qu'on
reconnaît que les victimes ne sont pas
des insurgés et c'est que ce sont des
victimes de cette répression non
reconnaît pas que c'est un crime d'état
et jacquet fait en catimini au lieu que
pour un fait aussi important il n'est
pas une déclaration de fête du cheval
chercheurs mot geek on a lieu symbolique
avec toulouse chaque fois que je serai
plus nechikh et poumons pas pour aller
plus loin on peut peut-être préciser les
événements qui se sont déroulés ce 17
octobre 1961 vous avez vu quelques
images d'un documentaire qui est sorti
l'an dernier ici on noie les algériens
on vous avait reçu sur ce plateau on en
avait parlé à cette occasion est
officiellement le préfet maurice papon
préfet de paris à l'époque la
déclaration était la suivante trois
morts officiellement ce n'est pas la
version vous soutenez un paquet que les
historiens de nombreux historiens bien
évidemment défendre tout à fait puisque
même même le photographe qui était dans
les locaux de l'humanité qui se trouve
en face du rex a plus les photos et des
nombreuses de priant que devant
l'humanité sur l'autre clark a en face
douze cadavres
ce soir là rien déjà sa version de cette
façon au moins 300 personnes qui ont été
tuées dans cette période alors ça
commence et les répressions un peu avant
le 17 octobre et ça continue un peu
après faut donc voir sur une oeuvre
toute une période
mais cet objectif était en fait un
objectif gouvernemental consciemment
élaboré entre papon michel debré et y
compris de gaulle à cette époque là
parce que de gaulle voulait à tout prix
obtenir un cessez-le-feu mais un conduit
à deux conditions
c'est de garder la souveraineté du
sahara et l'exploitation du pétrole
qu'on venait de découvrir quelques
années précédemment et le pouvoir ne
pensez pas la force du fln
or en région parisienne avec de l'ordre
de 150 mille algériens familles
comprises et dans cette manifestation il
ya au moins trente mille personnes qui
ont manifesté ce soir là et
contrairement ce que tu es gay non il ya
quelques jours il était en dimanche et
il avait mis couteau ni bâton ni quoi
que ce soit parce qu'ils veuillent des
consignes très strictes et un contrôle
et aucun algérienne était armé j'avais
même la cua chine de ne surtout pas
répondre à la provocation et j'ai été
envisagée est prévu frêche parce que
vous avez cité henri guaino on va
revenir justement sur cette déclaration
d'henri guaino le député de la 3e
circonscription députés ump la
déclaration le communiqué de françois
hollande a fait beaucoup parler vous
nous disiez que ça ne va pas encore
assez loin mais pour certains élus c'est
déjà allé trop loin et henri guaino qui
déclarait sur france inter c'était hier
matin que finalement les événements du
17 octobre ce n'était qu'une
manifestation qui avait mal tourné il a
fustigé l' acte de repentance du
gouvernement ce sont des propos qui vous
choque
sachant qu'ils également à l'ump
christian jacob ou encore françois
fillon également ont dénoncé ces propos
ce discours de culpabilité de la part du
chef de l'état sûr que ça me choque
profondément pour des raisons pour deux
raisons henri guaino était le
spécialiste de l'écriture des discours
de sarkozy qui avait trait aux questions
d'histoire c'est elle il a eu un diplôme
de licence d'histoire à la sorbonne
quand ils étaient jeunes et étudiants et
donc il devrait logiquement respecter
les faits historiques
or quand il parle que le
les faits ont dégénéré des deux côtés
c'est passé absolument pas vrai c'est un
mensonge et le grossier pour cent
qu'elle accréditer sa thèse de maintenir
une idée de colonialisme positif et ses
essais de discours de dakar ou celui de
toulon qui ont préparé le la politique
l'ania liste de sarkozy savoure montrer
comment est il
c'est un négationniste deux histoires et
qu'il adapte sa façon alors on revient
sur ses propos de françois hollande et
ses premiers pas en tout cas du
gouvernement aujourd'hui va concrètement
vous attendez quoi après c'est ce
communiqué qui a été publié
donc la semaine dernière par le
paralyser j'attends que en particulier
les actes suivent les paroles je prends
je prendrai deux exemples concrets le 20
octobre prochain il est prévu et je
viens de faire une lettre après midi le
drian le ministre de la défense
il est prévu à fréjus ou sur le mémorial
de la guerre d'indochine que le ministre
lui-même il ré au nôtre irait inauguré
la selle au colonel au général bigeard
dans ce général il a le triste privilège
d'avoir associé son nom aux crevettes
bigeard et ses crevettes bigeard c'est
quoi c'est lui ce sont des algériens qui
avec objets avaient décidé de
d'assassiner son jugement
sinon le sien et il est largué dans un
premier temps d'avions ou d'hélicoptères
de 300 mètres d'altitude ont retrouvé
son corps dans les montagnes ça faisait
problème donc pour fignoler les a jetés
dans la mer méditerranée
mais là mais il y en a quelques-uns qui
sont venus à la nage pour qu'ils ne
reviennent plus à la nage alors à
sceller les pieds dans un bloc de béton
et c'est cette technique a été exportée
par vos adresses trinquet lacheroy en
argentine pour faire disparaître les
trente mille disparus pleuré par les
folders sur la place de mai donc on
aurait 7 7 sp c'est remettre en cause
toutes les valeurs républicaines de la
france les droits de l'homme dans ce
domaine donc pour ce sera encore plus
symbolique en quelque sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de commémoration en l'honneur du
con leche la paix ou au centre de
bigeard et qu'on les mette la ba oui
mais pas avec un honneur officielle d'un
ministre qui va à qui va inaugurer natal
c'est une négation même des valeurs
républicaines et c'est en contradiction
puisque c'est une insulte aux algériens
puisque il ya tant de morts algériens
qui ont été torturées et exécutées par
par blizzard et ses troupes que c'est
une insulte propre aux algériens donc
ils vont en contradiction avec la
reconnaissance il ya l'autre fait qui
est aussi significatif c'est que dans la
quinzième de pau par exemple il ya
il ya deux ans l'équipe de sarkozy est
inaugurée une stèle à la loire du
château du colonel château jaubert jeu
ce militaire était un putschiste qui a
tenté de renverser la république en
avril 61 qui a déserté organiser le
maquis corse et nice pour contrôler le
cessez le feu en l'air et qui a été
condamné à mort on a fait en a mis sa
stèle je suis intervenu entre août pour
demander à ce qu'on n'ait pas une
commémoration comme c'était prévu dans
quelques jours dans cette caserne et
qu'on retire cette selle pour la medal
domaine privé au lieu de le public et
j'ai reçu une réponse de la présidence
de la république
donc juste avant cette déclaration
disons que j'étais normal que c'est elle
c'est le ji figure puisqu'elle avait été
demandé de façon égale
j'insiste pas trop le trouve sur mon
site elle est toute la justification
j'ai totalement aberrante et ça veut
dire qu'on donne un exemple aux jeunes
militaires qui sont en formation
vous pouvez déserté comploter contre la
république et un truc au dernier mort
est un honneur et c'est quand même une
remise en cause des valeurs
républicaines qui est inacceptable pour
vous le combat encore va se poursuivre
malgré ces premiers déclaration
puisqu'elle est encore des actes qui ne
sont pas forcément en adéquation avec la
déclaration de la semaine dernière et
puisque vous avez mentionné a
effectivement ces questions de torture
en algérie durant la guerre
d'indépendance je rappelle que vous
étiez le premier l'un des premiers en
tout cas lui certainement le premier à
dénoncer à la torture nous avait publié
des ouvrages autour de cette question
sur ces sources est question de la
torture merci d'être venu sur ce plateau
évoquer vos différentes réactions à ces
déclarations autour du 17 octobre 1961
merci r je vous mets dans un instant les
droits des chiens aux aveugles ils ne
sont pas acceptés par tous surtout
lorsqu'ils sont en formation une
difficulté supplémentaire pour l'heure m
explications à suivre avec notre
prochaine invitée auparavant nous
partons pour paris à une cérémonie a
lieu tous les jours à 18h30 devant l'arc
de triomphe en toute discrétion
l'allumage de la flamme du soldat
inconnu des jeunes de montigny et de
voisins-le-bretonneux viennent d'y
participer reportage
en route pour paris et son arc de
triomphe
ce soir là des jeunes de montigny et
voisins vont avoir le privilège de
participer à la cérémonie du ravivage de
la flamme sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
c'est une cérémonie assez importante à
laquelle nous avons les trois communes
concernées souhaité
impliquer nos conseil municipal des
jeunes parce qu'il nous a semblé que la
mémoire elle doit se transmettre sera se
raviver également et voilà pourquoi
aujourd'hui nos conseil municipal des
jeunes sont présents c'est warren kabedi
ancien président du conseil municipal
des jeunes de montigny qui a été choisie
comme porte drapeau jaune c'est
important pour toutes les personnes qui
sont là c'est une certaine fierté aussi
pour les jeunes les élus de ma vie mais
je suis content de le faire sans moi il
se rappelait qu'il ait eu la guerre et
de se rappeler qu'il ya des gens qui
sont morts pour nous
l'association des officiers de réserve
des yvelines a effectué tout un travail
de préparation auprès de ces jeunes à
propos de la finalité de cette cérémonie
car la guerre de 14-18 pour certains
c'est un peu flou reste le symbole on va
je pense que c'est très important
exactement qu'on soit là en tant que
j'aime ce qu'on existe en france donc je
pense que c'est un symbole est fort en
tout 60 jeunes civils et non avenues de
montigny voisins et viroflay ont
participé à cette cérémonie le ravivage
de la flamme a lieu tous les jours à
18h30 depuis 1923 en mémoire des soldats
français tombés pendant la guerre de 14